okay so let's uh let's start so the uh
last formal Talk of the afternoon is by
Emery Yoku from uh Carnegie Mellon
talking about weak versions of Accenture
resolution
um yeah so like the title suggests these
will be reached version whatever version
means yeah or extend resolution that are
still yeah
oh okay uh so that are still going to be
reasonably strong and those are uh of a
similar flavor to uh Jacob and meal
talks uh they looked at systems that are
on the higher end in terms of the
strength I will look at systems that are
on the lower end in terms of strength
that are still stronger than resolution
and we will be able to do uh interesting
things
so I will move a little bit quickly uh
through the preliminaries because most
of this has already been covered uh
there's one disclaimer though there will
be a lot of acronyms in the talk for
those proof systems try to ignore the
acronyms but I have to refer to those
systems by some names so they are
unavoidable okay so resolution is the
system that we will build our systems on
top of uh resolution you know refuted
propositional formula in CNF form by
using this single rule to derive the
empty clause and uh in case that is
confusing to some people whenever I say
proof I actually will mean reputation
throughout this talk so an example
resolution proof of this formula for
instance might be arranged in a tree by
fashion uh or it can be written down
like a sequence
for this talk I it will not make too
much of a difference because I will be
informal but I want you to think of uh
this like a configuration proof where
you X stand or contract instead of the
Clauses so you add stuff and then remove
stuff from sdnf actually and well so the
configuration version of this sequence
like proof would be you start with DMT
configuration and then you add this you
add this you add this at each step you
have a CNF and you add these until
finally adding the info
so yeah and extended resolution is a
extension of resolution where at any
step you can derive the three Clauses
expressing this uh where p and Q are
arbitrary withdrawals and X is the
number I say p and QR whichever but for
reputations there without loss of
penalty going to be the previously
occurring rituals uh in the formula they
can themselves be previously defined
extension variable so X is going to be
new
uh and yeah in this book I will talk I'm
going to consider the relative strengths
of uh weakenings of external solution
again whatever that means and
since I might run out of time because I
always do almost in talks I want to show
you the results first
uh so those are the systems that we're
going to be looking at okay a lot of
acronyms
uh so this minus indicates some
weakening of the system so without the
minus all of the systems that you hear
first of all each node is a built on top
of resolution and I've played them out a
little suggestively here
and but we'll come to that so the minus
indicates a weakening without minus all
of these are equivalent all of the
Accord systems that you've seen so
on top of resolution this BC system
is the weakest among all of those and
now think of having three axes here
along which you can generalize the
species system here you add something to
the system here you add another thing to
the system which is orthogonal and that
they can be combined and added together
to the system along this axis you add
something else again which can be
combined so for instance the system that
you see here can be thought of as a
marriage of this one and this one okay
so also moving out uh from the origin
you generalize the system so in an arrow
from a system to another means that
one sim likes the other so you have
simulations going uh in these directions
and these directions that are trivials
like this is Trivial as well and so this
is Trivial as well and the point of this
work is to look at the weakest
generalizations of this DC Vine system
which is a weak version of extend
resolution and show that okay they're
all incomparable they're qualitatively
different so they're quantitatively
different as well and so what about the
colors uh the black arrows were already
known mostly due to some percent meals
happens work
um the Red Arrows so this distinction
between red and green is for people who
might have seen a previous version of
this talk uh the red arrows are the new
results relative to the existing state
of knowledge before the earlier talks uh
that I gave on this the green arrows are
the new results since my the last time
that I gave this talk so I had like two
open questions those are no longer open
questions about the relationship between
this system to these systems and I
needed the lower bound on this system uh
to have those relationships so basically
the entire picture of those weakest
generalizations is now resolved and
the point is less about those systems
and more about the way you achieve those
they're all gonna follow very simple
recipe almost like a cheap trick for
proving the separations
and I repeatedly use it to get
separations in all of those ways
okay and still we need to appreciate
that you don't need to know about the
details of those systems although I will
try to tell you a little bit about them
so any questions at this point
yes this is the system for which we have
in our lower bonds so far so
okay
and so why you can tell about this
message Loop or being correspond but at
least the reason I care about this is
different than Jacob might care about
these systems uh so for me they
correspond to being able to say in your
proof of the words without loss of
Charity assume blah blah blah without
needing to introduce the emails so
expanded resolution can already do this
kind of reasoning but it can do much
more as well let's say you want to study
the weakest systems which still support
this kind of reasoning but do not have
to go all the way up to external
resolution because you want to do proof
complexity this time you want through
lower valves or separations between that
while still being strong enough in that
again this mostly follows uh from
Boston's work you have upper bounds for
all those hard tautologies uh in this
spr system some of those are not so
interesting uh but so from this point on
and here and then out of the wall uh the
systems start to get interesting
okay
um so for instance you can
exactly do this but effectively in those
systems you can say if I'm trying to
prove the pictional principle without
also jump the pigeon and plus one is
mapped to all that you don't literally
say this but you say something close to
this and then you derive this
is any questions no
no and like you saw in yakov's talk uh
this is based around the notion of
redundancy where you derive things that
are not uh necessarily implied but just
preserve Equity satisfiability when you
add them to the formula so you you'll
have your formula gamma which is the
formula in the configuration let's say
and you want to add a clause to it and
if it's redundant you can add it if your
goal is just to refute the formula and
this notion of uh characterizing the
redundancy is helpful for obtaining
various parameterizations of those
systems again you saw this in stock but
let me go over it again so we say Clause
is redundant with respect to formula
gamma
there exists some partial assignment
such that this holds so uh Jacob gave a
more technical explanation for uh this
characterization I like to think about
this a little bit more intuitively in
that this if this holds then you can say
without loss of child is C so why can
you do this suppose you are writing some
informal proof you have some lines at
some point you say without loss of
channel to see now you cannot just
continue you need to justify this step
that you've made and the way you justify
it is you reduce the proof of Nazi to
the rest of the proof with csues okay so
here what you do is okay I will not
explicitly prove this but you're saying
I will prove this from this point on
yeah well you will prove this is
unsatisfiable if this is unsatisfiable
then any restriction of it is also
unsatisfiable but if the other case here
actually implies this then just by
proving this you also prove this is
unsatisfiable
so this is the way at least I like to
think about this corresponding to being
able to say without the sub channels
questions
and of course that previous notion
involves implications so it doesn't give
you quick account proof systems yes
um so when you introduce this new scene
is it allowed to also introduce new
variables yes so so far I said nothing
about what C can be that's the way it's
all we will first generalize the
standard resolution and then we can
impact down to get systems between
resolution so yes here the C could be
just one of the Clauses uh corresponding
to the extension
so camera yes I like that explanation a
lot but it's sort of you're implicitly
using also that this implication is
something that is simple that we can
verify right yes
okay let me first let's see and undo the
proof and they say oh what if not see
well here's an easy reduction to what we
did before
yes for that reduction to be easily
verifiable you would need to use a
description of the uh
and that's where these uh actual
processes will not come in so we will
use syntactic criteria uh that will
automatically justify that that
relationship holds it may not be obvious
how this definition uh actually
corresponds to the thing that I've just
shown but soon I will use half this uh
ties together with that but let's parse
the uh definition together I will show
you more definitions but this is the
only one that I want you to be able to
follow because it's the simplest one and
I think it's reasonable uh although it's
late
so a clause of this form which includes
a distinguished virtual X
or C Prime is blocked for x
with respect to a formula gamma
for every Clause that contains not X in
the formula if you had result this
Clause with all those pauses or they all
would be topological so this is also the
motivation for why this was called
blocked because like it's blocked with
respect to taking results upon that
ritual so if you have such a clause then
adding it does not change and satisfy
with the status of the formula okay so
the definition is clear
so okay and by the way pathological
means some ritual occurs both positively
and negatively
is an example
so this is the formula this is the pause
I claim it's blocked for X with respect
to this formula you just need to look at
the causes where not X occurs
you have not X not y but the result
would be tautological because Y and not
y occur here it could be technological
because Z and not C occur here you don't
need to check anything okay so the
simple syntactic condition which you can
obviously check efficiently if even if I
didn't tell you what this x is
and here's why these things are
redundant so I claim that
thinking back to the characterization
that I've shown in the previous slide if
an assignment uh
so sets X to one then it is a witness uh
so I can knock the previous level
but why does it have to uh
satisfy this so
just take some total assignments Alpha
that satisfies this side it means that
that Alpha satisfies this and that Alpha
fulsifies this now I claim that uh the
right hand side here this gamma and c is
Satisfied by the composition and this
composition is again present in Jakob
stock apply Tau first apply Alpha later
which is just Alpha with alpha x squared
because Alpha was since C includes X was
assigning X to Zero now it's assigning X
to one
okay uh now C is satisfied but how about
Gamma so there may be some Clauses in
gamma who's satisfaction depended on uh
X being set to one I claim those are
also okay because uh there is some Y in
c c Prime which is the part of the C
without X such that the negation of Y is
in B Prime but since Alpha was
falsifying uh sorry falsifying C then it
still sets this y to zero
so nothing is broken like you had a
backup ritual uh which already satisfies
Clauses of this form so what you've done
is you've exhibited that if there's a
satisfying assignment to this then that
assignment satisfies this entire right
hand side okay
and you can now generalize this in
various ways I'll show you two of those
apologies for the name of this I did not
pick this and this asterisk is for
people who might have already seen this
definition uh this is different than the
definition that you're used to but it
gives a polynomial equal improved system
and this is simpler so I like it better
and everything is the same in the
definition except for this requirement
so you say here this is totalogical here
you say this is subsumed by gamma and
subsumed means that there is some clause
in gamma of which this is a big thing
and the intuitive way to think about
this is these are saying without losing
channels where the justifications in the
case of block Clauses is local because
it cannot look too much in gamma uh
aside from the Clauses that include not
X but this for here you can look
anywhere in gamma to find a reason uh
why you're good
okay so this is one axis along which you
can generalize control system you can go
up uh okay so this is maybe a little bit
more complicated notion of a set block
Clause here instead of uh this x being a
literal it's a set of literals
and again you have this extra condition
which is kind of like this generalizes
this and this extra condition which is
kind of like this okay
again zoom out
completely tried to parse let's just
look at the shapes to see that this is
indeed a generalization because if this
was a single literal
this would be the same like set flow
Clause with a single visualize L would
be block a block loss okay so now we
have proof systems uh using these
Notions built on top of resolution
okay uh so resolution and extension
gives you exam resolution uh BC is
resolution plus blocked Clause Edition
BC minus is BC without new variables
which means that the newly derived
Clauses cannot include any numerables so
these are a weakening of external
resolution in sense that this is a
generalization of extra resolution and
this is how we restrict it back in a way
that still makes sense and it doesn't
just become resolution something
actually exponentially stronger than
resolution Xbox will represent extent
resolution
and there's this notion of deletion
which again came up in the previous
talks
I do not want to get too much into it
but being able to remove an app Clauses
makes a difference to the strengths of
those proof systems because inferences
in those systems are non-monotal so in
general if from a formula you can derive
a clause if that formula was larger you
could still derive that cause nothing is
broken it doesn't hold such a thing
doesn't hold necessarily for those
career systems if you had extra things
if you're without loss of channels you
think May no longer hold so deletion
makes a difference to those systems and
you have like versions of this for rats
SBC Etc and like I said spr I'm just
naming it because it's a particular
strong one SPI is like the marriage of
SVC times rad Edition Essence for SVC uh
subset propagation redundancies yes
question yes you mentioned that BC and
BBC are generalizations
DC is a transitional expansion PR is a
generalization of Peace when you say
generalization what do you mean are they
from approves
complex I mean a strong MBC proof is
literally correct as a PR proof
or an extended resolution proof where
you add the Providence uh you're gonna
add the three pauses that correspond to
the extension accent it's literally a BC
uh valid in BC or similarly like foreign
[Music]
so I said we are looking at the versions
and this is the kitchen property the key
weird property of those systems that I'm
Gonna Keep exploiting to get uh
separations
effectively this is the technical term
effective simulation but with an
asterisk because it's not actual
literally corresponding to the way it
was defined effectively BC minus without
new variables simulate CR
and I will not Define effect but
effectively polynomial simulations are
but just exhibited with an example so
they're results of this one
suppose that a formula gamma has an ER
proof of sometimes
and consider this set of variables which
are not shared with yeah
if you just attach this to gamma then
the new formula has a short BC minus
proof well because those are new
variables but technically they're not
not now they're in the formula okay so
this is like a trick but this trick is
useful for instance in this way you can
very cheaply separate BC minus
chromosomes yes so could you use this to
say let's resolve away a few variables
make up some room
and now let's let's that's how one of
the simulations goes actually yeah
between the versions
uh okay let me show you at least one
consider just one extent one use of the
extensional like I said they're doing
repetition without those security these
the children are not new so yeah at
least causes and sequences these are not
quite corresponding to this because you
pick up this extra nut why but for that
reason you include uh y as a cause so
then you just resolve those away and you
have the three Clauses corresponding to
this and the rest is like the resolution
steps are the same so this is how that's
simulation Works since BC minus does
this all of the systems do this
and
You by between tweak this uh set that
you're including uh with the formula to
get easy separations between all of
those systems
so I'm calling these guarded extension
variables the terminology is borrowed
from uh
regular resolution versus resolution
paper where they're actually guarding
Clauses uh so it's a little different
but it's roughly the same idea so yeah I
decided to call them guarded extension
variables so we will start with a
formula with a short CR proof and keep
in mind this which makes uh this formula
easy for BC we will now to separate two
systems p and Q which generalizes BC
minus we will incorporate extension
variables in ways that are useful to
only one of the two systems
and uh so the idea is I will guard
somehow guard the variables but by guard
I mean they will not be included plainly
like this I will have some Gadget like
things though they're not exactly
gadgets but like small formulas uh in
which these appear but not as openly as
this and then one of the systems will be
you able to use these variables to
simulate the ER proof as before although
a little in a slightly uh more
complicated Manner and the other one
although these are just there will be
unable to achieve any speed up
and how you can achieve this kind of
thing is not obvious probably but uh it
is just like a completely trivial
example so consider this formula and
suppose you're trying to add somewhere
some some Clause that's blocked for x
so we remember the definition of block
causes uh which says that formula has to
that Clause has to include Clash against
this uh claw then this Clause when you
resolve it upon X but well or the only
thing to clash against are is y here and
not y here then that Clause has to
include both why and not y so that's a
useless Clause okay so in this way you
can like impose uh restrictions on the
sets of uh Clauses that are derivable
within uh these uh proof systems
um
I had a example lower bond in the
simplest case to show that that easy if
you're used to those systems I'll just
show you
how shortages okay there are like some
llamas here it's some steps are levels
but uh this kind of a formula which is
basically a generalization of the
example that I've just shown you is no
easier than the original formula gamma
for this PC minus system and proving a
lower bound is MVC minus is really weak
so that's why it's so short but still
this is quite uh easy compared to yeah
or another one at least
and actually this kind of a formula ends
up being easy for red mines so this is
for instance the construction that we
can use to separate red minus and BC
minus why it's easy uh I cannot get into
right now
but I will show you the constructions
that I use to separate all pairs of
those systems just I flash them and then
uh
I have a few minutes and I will move to
discussion so and you actually have a
real economy of uh constructions in that
using a simple single construction you
prove that two systems do not simulate
this system and one thing that I want to
emphasize about this approach is so this
formula this new formula this the new
variables becomes easy for red minus
regardless of whether gamma is so you
take any formula that separates that
minus from ER minus that is so from ER
and you plug it here and you get your
separation okay
now you only need to think about how to
construct
uh there's a different kind of
construction where you have like
multiple uh literally you just this just
says X is equal to y i well rats for
some reason is unable to make any use of
the x's and y's here but this formula
ends up being easy for both of the other
systems of different features and okay
SBC is possibly the most interesting
system among the three so to break it
you have to work a little bit more and
then you have this kind of construction
where X is supposed to be the new
variables that are to be used and ger
can just work through all of this and
use this x to derive the extension
causes SPC looks at this and says I
cannot do anything
unless you give me an exponential
so using these kinds of like cheap
tricks you can separate all of those
systems
and yeah I have a few open classes so
spr minus uh going back to this picture
um this is like the frontier in terms of
lower bonds against all systems because
this is known to the uh not
polynomically bounded so is this so is
this and so is this as part of this
world and these are probably really hard
to grow lower bonds against so that
leaves spr so spr minus is the system
that uh bus and happen formulated most
of their upper bounds and some of those
upper bounds hold in STC minus uh I
don't know if
it's here but antenna was talking about
uh differences in encoding between
Christians and like the same tautology
being easy and difficult on the
different encodings for instance here
for this system both the original
principle and the bit original principle
are easy for this system original
principle is easy but with original
principle is hard and here if you
understand the definition like once you
understand the definitions of those
systems it literally it makes a lot of
sense that this is the case because this
system is unaware in its justifications
of the entire formula but the original
principle in a sense is Meaningful more
globally right so subsets of it are a
little less meaningless are a little
more meaningless than uh the units
so yeah this is like Frontier in terms
of lower branch and we want separations
using natural principles as everyone
says
and the third is about connecting the
study of those systems to the rest of
proof complexity so right now those are
like Niche and kind of new systems so
they're disconnected from the rest of
proof complexity what you what we know
for instance is uh any system that's
caused on the restrictions does not seem
like even the weaker system unless that
system also simulates extended but
that's not but I'm more curious about
the converse uh kind of results in that
it so this is standing for the strongest
versions of those systems without new
variables is there any subsystem I
forget about strictly about resolution
that you can simulate in those systems
anything or are they completely
incomparable uh with the rest of the
for systems that are commonly studied
and I also I like this idea although
it's a hack uh I would like to see like
other uses of the high level idea I have
one idea uh where this can be used and
if you've heard of it it's linear
resolution versus resolution because the
linear resolution has some weird
properties that are similar to the
system that I've talked about so
potentially it could be applied to
separate those which is I wouldn't say a
long-standing open problem but an old
open problem
okay
the question yes
effectively simulation which of those uh
incomparabilities
the difference
effective simulations
in this case if you don't know how many
extensionalities
um
so I actually know
we probably do not stimulate we are in
the sense of the correct definition of
effective simulations
or when you asked about separations
across those
because lots of flavors of resolution
collapse together
under effective way based on some of the
existence of they may end up collapsing
because there are simulations where you
allow just one extra variable and then
you can see my things but that uses
deletion
any questions
just just a quick one so res two so are
there separations can you prove that res
2 can't be simulated by uh some of these
systems
are for
so a digital principle is hard here but
it's also hard there
uh
is hard here but it's also hard
remaining
[Music]
an easy formula for S2 is the click
coloring with very big gap between the
coloring is easy here and here
is
here and here because you can't say
without lots of penalty the elements the
first step and third the federal element
of the three is one two three so that is
expressible here and here
if you would like to to write a solver a
practical server which which one of
these language do we use I mean to add
something that is efficient to this from
realistics and
um
the difficulties
yeah even if you claim the formulas it's
only working on pigeon all right yes
so I I like this as well this one yeah
you're talking about the satisfaction
driven sorry uh they use some version of
SVC or ssbc minus I guess in their thing
and I think I think it's a version of
SPC minus okay and it makes sense here
yeah that only works in a really
specific cases right it's not like
you know
well
but it worked rather well for certain
types of digital principles let's say it
that way
here is
I can say that we have tried to build an
stcl solver and it works well for
certain kinds of problems with not other
kind of elements and one of the one of
the issues that we Face there is
so if you I mean the source code for
this sdcl solvers online and I had a
couple undergraduate students ran last
quarter and they were able to to get the
same results using their software of
course but when they used randomly
permuted versions of visual principle
they use a very particular branching
heuristic that's kind of information
but it's interesting they're able to
find more or less the optical principle
reputations of size around n huge up to
over 50 pigeons which is a pretty
amazing number
oh and on that note so the system here
that's just outside
called PR and actually a short proof of
wrestling example uh from the first day
literally
um
okay so that's also like that
all right well let's uh thank you
American
[Applause]
foreign